the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so let's get started so before I
get into any folder I want to talk about
the mentality I want everyone to try to
have when analyzing poker in this class
so I call the decision mentality so I'm
going to start with this story
here's your sort of credit card roulette
it's like a game you play at the end of
going to restaurants so what happens is
poker players they're going to split the
bill by instead of everyone paying your
own bell which is annoying right you
have to like keep track you might have
to bend on people after the exact amount
and sometimes the waiter or waitress
doesn't want to split the bill per
person so poker players get around this
by just picking one person up rained it
to pay the bill and you know we like
getting this exciting so what we do is
we have everyone to put in your credit
card and then we pull out the credit
cards one at a time and if your credit
card is pulled out then you're safe and
the last person in has to pay for the
whole table so yeah so it's a pretty fun
game I think yeah I think I'm pretty
lucky yeah it is the biggest one I lost
was in Hong Kong I want that to Kate
around 1200 USD it was a pretty big
table um but overall I'm pretty good at
this game
yeah you must kill Richard so alright so
but sometimes this results in some funny
stories with non poker players so this
is something that happened to some poker
players also huger Pro Matt here's the
dinner with poker pro Steven and in that
bring Emily he was a close friend whom
he also has a magic interest in so when
the bill comes Matt's like okay I'm
going to pay for Emily so he puts in two
credit cards he's like the second credit
card is for speed is for Emily and they
had Steven page themself so Steven puts
in one credit card so they starts play
credit card roulette and then Matt being
a very lucky guy pulls out both of his
credit cards before Stevens and Steven
end up paying for all three of them okay
so now the question is who should Emily
take this so this is Sophie would you
take it to write Emily's shoes now did
they go on to say st. Stephen okay
Steven actually pays for the meal right
so I think it's totally reasonable thing
to do as a reasonable person to take
- actually a people is wallet so in this
class we want everyone to think in terms
of expected results and not actual
results so Emily should be safer than
that you get on average Matt put in the
card for Emily and on average that is
going to be paying for Emily because not
going to be paying the 1/3 of the time
that Emily with these things but at the
time
Emily st. Stephen for the meal and then
didn't say anything back and then that
was it said about an entire folder
Thursday that's all I'm serious
okay so right so we want to think about
in terms of six on average what your
decision would have had what would have
made whether you would have made money
in expectation or on average so roughly
the law of large numbers says over your
lifetime the amount you end up hanging
from credit credit less is the same as
we want to page from splitting the bill
so you know why split the bill you might
as well just save a lot of time by
playing this fun game every single time
and over your lifetime the amount you'd
pay in credit card roulette is roughly
going to be what he would have paid from
sleep and so you so all randomness
eventually averages out to its expected
value that's what this is saying um so
what does eventually mean
so basically when we say a gamble is
very risky
I'm not mathematically defining anything
here but I just want to throw up them
intuitive concepts so what a risky
gamble is a gamble where it takes a long
time to converge at your expectation but
the point is no matter how big it is
eventually it'll get II so hope your
players so hear the saying that like
debts taxes or the two things that
eventually get out here let's hope your
players we like we think that three
things eventually get at you is death
taxes and the law of large numbers we'll
eventually you're going to reach your
longer okay so so here's another
hypothetical situation so let's say you
can't let the long bus stop because you
were distracted and then you're upset
yourself do you analyze how to not get
distracted in the future and get up at
the right bus stop but then after you
get up at the wrong bus stop you find a
thousand others on the ground and then
you immediately you're no longer upset
in your marble white your riches so this
is sort of an absurd story but
situations like this happen all the time
in poker
you're going to make a bad decision but
a bad decision still get a good result
49 percent of the time and it makes the
right right decision
you're still going to get a bad result
forty nine percent of the time so it's
very important to analyze your decisions
without being biased by the actual
outcome that that that occurred so you
really want to be obsessive looks like
self-improvement analyzing your
decisions you know if you made like ten
thousand dollars in the situation where
you could have made twelve thousand then
that's not good enough so I want
everyone to think in terms of you know
what's the maximum you could have made
and analyzing what's the best decision
you could have possibly made in every
situation
and sometimes it's four eight because if
the result is exactly correlated with
the decision then you can just go back
and look at the result and know whether
you made a good decision or not but
that's why learning poker can sometimes
be very very hard because you don't have
immediate feedback you're not sure
whether the decision you made was is
what caused you to make that money or
you just got lucky
okay so with that being said so now
let's talk about some way to reason
about poker hands so roughly there's
three levels of reason inappropriate
hands so level one is my hand versus
your hand so but by this i name you you
can see what your cards are and you can
look into your opponent's eyes and you
say okay I can tell your part must be
pocket kings or whatever your hand don't
hand up to this other hand and you play
your hand exactly against your
opponent's specific hand because you
have a soul breeze on them so I select
an example of this so we'll watch out a
episode of Poker After Dark here raise
to 12
you know you are creepy
think you would call it the confirm
button race is never anything contrary
to what Patrick lightning Jennifer has a
real hand and it just got better she
flopped top set Patrick plot the pair of
tens with a gut shot straight draw
gucchi
who has
I can be radical so just and you had
pocket kings I was like almost forgotten
okay so so yes this is a sort of well
known culture kind of way back in the
day if you're a jennifer Tilly hand I'm
sorry if I'm making better here but
basically right so she put her opponent
on a specific hand she listed Patrick
Antonius and had a feeling that you have
pocket kings for some strange reason and
then what happened was so she has pocket
jacks here which is a really really good
hand at the full helps and she just
checked the turn and checked the river
instead of trying to get after to put
more money in because she was so certain
Patrick had pocket kings and you know
it's mathematically speaking out of all
the possible combinations of currency
could have to put your opponent
specifically on pocket kings in this
example is basically unfounded so this
gets to level two reasoning solo to
reasoning is the morning hand versus
your range of hands versus your
probability distribution and another
name for this is exploitative play so
let's look at the different hand and I'm
going to show you how to reason about
this hand using level two exploitative
reasoning so okay so I'm not going to go
through the whole hand but this is
actually a real hand I played in Macau
five six years ago so we get to the
river and I have East ten and in this
situation so the pot is twenty one
thousand roughly and my opponent bets
eight that is sorry so the pot is twenty
one thousand after my opponent bets
eight thousand so basically the top it's
13,000 and my opponent that eight
thousand making it twenty one thousand
and I have to decide whether she call
what the pretty good hand have a pair of
aces here but I know my opponent is
ranked on who is a very tight player and
doesn't really like bluffing so I don't
think he's really ever bluffing
if I'm meeting him here it's because
he's betting a hand that
things is good but it's actually worse
than mine like 8/8 basically so a lot of
my opponents range as ace king through a
sage I don't think he had something even
stronger what pocket knife because you
would have raised more earlier in the
hand but basically okay so let me let me
run through this calculation sort of
slowly for those of you seeing pot odds
for the first time so here basically I
want to think of it like this
the pot which includes the thousand you
just put out is twenty one thousand
we're considering calling for eight
thousand so if we lose if we call it he
terms of each King which is a better
hand than our net result from this
decision is negative eight thousand
dollars if we waiting together eight
thousand back as well as the twenty one
thousand the top so we make our net is
plus twenty one thousand
so therefore our women to lose ratio
needs to be at least eight thousand to
twenty one thousand in order for calling
to be positive expectancy so all right
so what are the exact calculation I'll
try to do it somewhat slowly to show an
example of how to do this calculation so
essentially what I do is I count the
combination of I count the combinations
of each hand that exists so Ace King
there's eight combat ace king their
state combination see there's two aces
remaining that I headed seen and there's
four kings army so it's two times four
there's a combination same with ace
Queen
ace Jack an ace ace ace ten and eight
nine there's only six combinations each
because I have the time which makes him
having a ten less likely and for each
nine there's an eye on the board so each
night it helps with slightly less likely
so each time we actually get half the
pot so I'm just going to roughly I'm
gonna make that equivalent to us winning
three of those times of us losing three
of those columns which is equivalent in
expectation so basically it is counting
there's thirty three combinations that
beat us there's a loving combinations
that we beak and so our equity is
basically our probability of winning
which is equivalently the fraction of
the pot that we own so our equity in
this case is twenty five percent and the
pot odds are 21 and eight and then so we
need we need basically one over
3.56 so 21 to 8 is 2.5 61 we need
equities 1 over 3.5 6 to call which is
28% which we don't have so I fold it
oops sorry
so so I'm so unfortunately this
calculation is a bit ugly you just have
to do it a bunch of times and convince
yourself that you're doing the right
calculation basically you got to
remember to add 1 when you're converting
the odds ratio to a equity but it um but
yes so it it should be fairly simple
math but um so in this case I folded
because I didn't have this desired ugly
it so is there any questions about that
that was maybe a bit confusing but I
don't know the great way to it I don't
know the great way to sort of show the
exact conversion from pot odds into
equity but I just want to point out that
they're slightly different just one is
one is a ratio of when you lose and one
is basically a fraction of win over all
possible outcomes so just don't get
confused like this value I'm saying I'm
going to sort of quickly interchange
between the two throughout the course
and you should try to get in a habit of
being but it quickly compute between the
two okay so this is an example of level
two reasoning and hand reading is about
using your opponent's past actions and
your knowledge of their tendencies to
tweak your probability distribution over
what you think their hand is so cane
reason that hand reading is not about
taking your opponent on a specific hand
so you know sort of marketing methods
poker players they were sunglasses they
have ear applied to prevent people from
reading their soul I mean it matters a
bit but really these things you know
things like I scratch my here before I
agrees it should affect your belief of
my cards a very strong way less than
what Lady Gaga in the media makes it
seem like okay so I so that's sort of
how your reason is out of hand
exploitative Lee you build a model for
how your opponent behaves and you make
the decision that's the most positive
expectancy against that model and you
can go very very far with level two
reason you know you can basically build
a career out of love
reasoning and that's targeted towards
individual opponents with specific
tendencies that you're trying to take
advantage of so okay so this sounds
really good this sounds great with great
way to play poker I I can figure out
what my phone is doing right I I just I
figure out the probability distribution
and play in a way to make the most money
from this so does anyone have does
anyone have any problems with this type
of reasoning so okay so I've got some
$20 Amazon gift certificates from a Kuna
capital so I'm going to point out
potentially something you don't like
about this type of reasoning I'll give
you this gift certificate yeah you're a
lot of information about what you had is
when you think like that you right but
what if your model incorporates the fact
that they're gonna behave based on what
they think is in your hand
yeah well I mean it might take you a
long time to build this model and it
players leave your table or whatever
like you spend like because before you
have the model you can't use this by
embracing those expensive tooling
right yeah that's a good point yeah so
so Cyril yeah this so for it's a level
two reasoning is not easy even though it
has flaws even playing very good level
to poker is not easy building the model
can be very hard and you could be wrong
yeah but that's not really what I'm
looking for um yeah Colin yeah um
because your opponent knows he reasoning
he could maybe bet a certain way to push
it to 20% there he'll only calls it
right okay okay yeah um okay I think
I'll be good enough okay I'm going to
get I'm gonna give this video I'll give
it to you at the end okay right so so
essentially so it's actually yeah the
problem is the so this is assumption the
fatal flaw in every plan is the
assumption that you know more than your
heading
does anyone know where this is from by
the way if you do have another $20 okay
if anyone know where this phrase is from
yeah right right Hollywood's no
yeah that's the AuSable amen okay it's
okay no one else again all right so
essentially the problem with this line
of reasoning is your opponent does not
play according to a fish that elevator
there are also an intelligent human
who's taking this class who's building
all those for you and adapting the
chance givi eat right so if you assume
your opponent plays the stick strategy
but what if they're doing the scene for
you so so now I'm going to get you the
third level of reasoning which I call
optimal play so let's analyze the exact
same hand using level three beating so
don't get me wrong level two reasoning
is great if you can do little to
reasoning very well you can make the
tendon life but level three reasoning is
a completely different way to analyze
this hand that can also make you a lot
of money so okay so level three
reasoning I'm going to think like this
into the thinking so
level three is my range of hands over
your brain Japan's so instead of looking
at my specific cards and figuring out
like carbs arms I'm actually going to
also put it this probability
distribution over myself and that's
myself so my opponent dies what is the
probability distribution of my hand and
in this specific spot let's just say I
decide that my range in this pot is east
Jack through 87 so not including a snack
at basically HIV days ten days 87 so
this is the way to do the calculation so
I let this assume I know my opponents
propensity is today 1 1 over 1.6 percent
of the pot on the river so roughly in
this pot so the pot was 13,000 on the
river and I know that my opponent could
have bet 8,000
so and so I must call it the frequency
such that they're easy from bluffing is
0 so not potentially my goal was optimal
play so essentially what I'm saying is
let's say they have a really bad thing
they have like jack 10 for Jack high
which is almost certainly going to lose
the pocket if they don't best to try to
get me to fold then I want to call with
the frequency such that with those hands
regardless of whether they Bluff there
zero so how do I do that I just make my
call default ratio one point six to one
so in all these computations to make it
easier I'm assuming I'm rough one point
six is like approximate for the ratio
it's actually thirteen over eight but I
chose it actually turned out to be
mostly Fibonacci numbers so the ratio is
around one point sixty one for album so
I'm making a circuit okay so my called a
full ratio needs to be one point 61 so
that if they have a bad hand their
expectation from from bluffing is zero
it doesn't matter whether they block so
if I do this calculation then then eight
tenths or intercept I pole is 10 is
definitely in the top 61.5% of hands I
can you call it have so I need to call
okay so I'm not building a probability
model for them what I'm essentially
saying is if I'm not calling H down here
then they can exploit me by bluffing too
much and I'm just holding all my hands
here and they're going to be able to
make money off of me
to prevent this I must call 810 which is
a 61.5% I'll and in my range so that
they can't explain it so I'm going to
make an analogy with RPS so
rock-paper-scissors does everyone
already play the same so you are there
to rock scissors or paper so there's
going to do it as this game I know
people if you grew up in two different
background I call it something else or
you might have different roles but the
robot play with is rock beats scissors
scissors these paper and paper beats
Rock okay so so actually pay to exploit
a display you think like this you say
since my opponent just played rock three
times in a row I think they're probably
not going to play a rock a fourth time
in a row so I'm going to play scissors
because I have like an DP
optimal play just said I'm going to
memorize a sequence of random bits and
always play each of rock paper and
scissors with probability 1/3 so this is
an analogy with rock paper scissors and
so one of us should often get is you
know it when you play optimally you're
making all your opponent's decisions the
same then your opponent essentially is
never making in the state because
regardless what they do it
saying that how do you make money
playing oftenly so in
rock-paper-scissors that's true you know
by tragedy exist please
rock-paper-scissors each with
probability 1/3 I'm never going to beat
you more often than I should but in
poker there's enough opportunities to
essentially be inconsistent for it for
example like sometimes you'll see
players fold 7 6 suited and then because
later that are like bored and feel like
playing a worst handbill like call 6 5
suited in the exact same situation which
is like basically making a strictly
dominated strategy or like check raising
the circle inferior range it's actually
the theoretical optimal strategy we'll
still extract money slowly from even the
best players because even the best
players in poker right now there's going
to be slight inconsistencies that are
not theoretical is radically optional so
it's actually ok so this so the optimal
strategy another way to promote it is a
Nash equilibrium if you've heard of the
term because the best response to the
optimal strategy is the optimal strategy
itself whereas the best response to any
exploitative strategy is going to be a
different strategy whenever you play an
exploitative strategy you stand to be
beaten by a different exploitive
strategy that reexpose you so on so this
is a different optimal players who play
each with the same probability often
pleasure and different to your
opponent's move so often we'll plays
you're making a lot of money when your
opponent doesn't makes your place of
optimal where as an exploitative play
you make a lot of money when you're
winning the mind games and you lose a
lot when you're losing them you know so
it's excellent shaded play sort of like
I know that you know that I know that
you know that I know this but you know
that I know that you know that I know
that you know that I know this so
basically you're going to do these mind
games and if you're good them then it's
pretty good right if you're playing
rock-paper-scissors against a 4 year old
child probably you don't want to play
optimally probably you want to like look
at their stage and try to figure it out
what they're going to do and try to beat
them right but if you're playing
rock-paper-scissors against the
rock-paper-scissors world champion which
there is one actually then probably you
just want to memorize this
the random bit and clay probability 1/3
so another good thing to an exploitative
play is it's intuitive you know we're
sort of we sort of grew up thinking in
terms of exploitative play right I think
I think I'm a fair statement you know in
most things it's like what do you think
might happen if that might happen ok
I'll do this but optimal play sort of a
weird mentality because it's sort of
like I don't understand oh I analyze
what my opponent could eventually do so
you need an opponent essentially and
then I'm just going to perform an action
that sort of makes it so that my can't
really be here ok so that's the mess
about those two general concepts I'm
going to take a short break right here
this is good timing so I'm going to
continue on and now we'll get into
Maxwell holder but first okay we're
gonna play one last game so ok I'm gonna
put we're to play a game or who's taller
ok
anyone can join the contest for a dollar
okay we're not actually having this so
don't get out your wallet okay
basic plain ok so and then that's all
experts will be joining the game gets
the entire pot so all of them all the
money all the people we joined the game
we're going to enter who's the tallest
and the mattress and get everyone's
night okay so we put it up everyone
close your eyes so that you can't look
in here everyone close your eyes no
peeking no peeking it how okay so
everyone close your eyes is it written
up close okay so put up your hands if
you want to join the contest so to the
nice and high so that I can see if you
wanna join the contest
alright so kids so if you're either hand
highly it's okay there's no
embarrassment double point of Poker is
work okay cool so now everyone open your
eyes okay so I think five people join me
okay so do you guys come down here let's
see you
don't be shy enjoy this okay it's
totally okay to watch um okay so I think
the four of you okay Justin okay so I
think just another one so I get out
Justin you would have introduction
alright cool so okay what the point of
this game um the point of this game is
so from a game theoretic point of view
no one really should be playing this
game so this is only known as the kuv
game if it's from Game three so also let
this house already Justin six five okay
so why does it play the game because you
thought there's probably someone who's
going to be like six two who might play
the game right so right but if you but
if everyone knew that you know if you're
only six two you shouldn't be playing
this game because someone might be six
five
then you wouldn't play the game right
because someone else is only going to
play the game if they were like six
eight or something right so essentially
basically once you select a would play
the team again probably only just play
um eventually this game always develops
through a situation where no basically
no one is willing to join because you
know that no matter even if you're like
7 feet tall you're LeBron James you
would know that someone would only play
this game if they were the tallest
person in the world essentially so
basically poker without blinds which is
the money that's put into the pot at the
start of every hand would essentially be
like the tuesd holiday so when you play
poker you want the motivation of every
hand to be stealing the line the only
the money that was forced into the pot
without the choice is the person so you
would always fold King King which is the
second best invoker preflop if there
were no blinds so okay let's so suppose
we were to play who's taller again but I
told you that I'm going to force swing
over you to play okay
so then so now we've got a game because
now even if you're not sure or whether
you're the tallest person in the room
if you're sure if you're taller then
bloomer rate then you have a chance of
winning so that's essentially help why
we need blind to family so basically you
want to think of so you always want to
think of how many chips you have in
terms of the blinds and so having $400
in front of you in a game with the
blinds are one $1 $2 for our purposes is
equivalent to having $4,000 in front of
you and in a game where the blinds are
$10 and $20 because essentially
everything you're wagering is relative
to stealing the blinds that were forced
into the game at the beginning so in
both of these situations we say that you
have 200 zaps or 200 big blinds or 200
BB okay so so that's how to calculate
your stack size but what's actually
important is in fact is that effective
snack size so effective snack size takes
into account the stack sizes of the
people remaining in the pot as well so
okay so I'll give an example so in this
case this so were the player with the
jack and we decided to go all-in
so what is our exact back side so the so
the big blind is 2000 - small - 1000 and
we wagered into a little 42,000 so what
there's what's our sec side with the 21
right it's essentially is around 20 at
any one big blind but we didn't really
risk 21 big blinds here did we um did
someone okay I'll give her $20 gift
certificate how much did we actually
risk it sometimes yeah I can't see
quibble but I speak 12 and a half big
one okay yeah exactly
okay I'll remember I'll put it here okay
so right so we only risks 12 and a half
big blinds because the everyone in front
of us has our folded and the two players
behind the small blind in the big blind
one of them only had seven and a half
big blinds and the other one only has 12
and a half three one is ever going to
decimal even though you know
UTG plus two
it has 32 and a half lines could have
theoretically covered us and we could
have could have theoretically taken our
money but on this hand because they
already folded we're essentially only
risking at most 12 and a half big blinds
that's the most we can lose so we can't
be eliminated from the tournament this
can't so here's another example so here
you see this guy that I'm going to call
a LoJack for now you see him going for
16 big blinds um so in this case
technically if you could lose all his
life because having more than 16 bit
honey and we do cover them but you know
in reality I think he's probably not
on average risking 16 big blinds because
most of the people who could call them
other than UPS have way less than 16 big
blinds does that make sense
so essentially so there's not like an
exact formula for of sax noise but you
want to sort of think of it in terms of
you look at the stack sizes with all the
people you could potentially play the
hand against suit and you want to look
at you know roughly how much am I going
to be risking in this hand okay okay so
that's detective session is that
everyone okay okay so the second thing I
want talk about that's very important is
position so position is basically where
you are at the table relative to the
blind so how many players are remaining
to compete versus me for the blind
essentially the fewer players better
left the less strong my in need to be to
attack points so I'm going to give names
for the positions basically the thing
that matters is how far you arcing this
button so in this example with ace Jack
when everyone folded to you and you're
on the you're the dealer which is also
known as the button essentially to steal
the blinds you just need to get through
the tube lines themselves so that's
essentially two plays and then you know
if you're in one position earlier when
it was folded to cut off then you had to
deal with three players so you want to
name everything relative to the dealer
eventually so we can just quickly go
through the names they'll get more
familiar as time goes on so so the first
person to act is we
under the gun so that's that's this guy
here and we go around the tables under
the gun plus one on this gun plus two
there's so there are ten of these
different names for the same position so
in in this specific hand where there
were only six players at the table you
know you could have caused a little jack
under the gun because under the gun is
the first person to act to the left of
the big blind but essentially it's more
clear to say low Jack because when you
say under the gun you have to say under
the guy that is six handed table and
then people will know okay that means
you got to get through five hands but if
you say little jacket area clear you
have to get through to five hands so I
did the gun and then plus two and then
low jab you can also call under the gun
plus two lowjack minus one if you want
and then highjacked cut off button don't
ask me where these name came from I
actually have showing you okay and it's
what line big light so okay so that's
position and importance of position is
basically the later you are is the fewer
in hands you got to get through to steal
the button to steal the blinds if
everyone had started folding okay so the
third thing is that matters in a poker
hand is equity so we talked about sack
size you talks about a position the last
thing is actually your cards so the
equity of your card is basically your
secret height for the humans tolerating
so you can think of it like that your
card is like your secret ID and the
probability of you winning the pot or
equivalently the fractions of Paju would
win once the remaining cards are dealt
is called your equity okay I'm going to
give some examples of calculating equity
so here's an example where it's we get
it all in on the turn and so I have five
four of spades here so I'm not in a
great position but let's try to count
how many out how many outs I have so
this I want to just name a river card
that would help me win the part seven of
eight so that gives me a straight and
flush actually so okay so let's go along
those lines so how many stages are there
left in the deck
oh yeah United States right now in state
and then how many harder to help me make
it straight
right a seven or - right so it's six
more because it's eat sevens and choose
but I'm giel counting the seven of space
and the two of speed so that's 9 plus 6
and then I actually subtract one more
card
does anyone see what it is yeah right in
the Queen of Spades because that's
actually a disastrous situation because
then if it wasn't all and I would
probably put in more money on the river
in India have a flush and lose doable
house right so it's working out 17-3 our
equity is around 32% at 14 over the 44
cards decorate still come okay does that
make sense to everyone so that's one way
of calculating equity it's just a very
simple probability distribution over the
remaining card from the deck back of
shop and you know if you if you're
worried like you know what if someone
folded the Queen of Spades so I
shouldn't be counting that essentially
you just want to pretend that the
current owner of the month like the card
that were folded by other players
they're essentially irrelevant because
you know they could have folded the
Queen of Spades that they could have
also folded an in relevant part like the
Jack of Hearts or something so
essentially you just wanted all the
cards that you have a team it's easier
to just assume that they don't expect
anything I mean in theory they touch
kings of this because you know if you
know that if you know that the dealer
button folds it's two cards even if you
don't know what they are they're
probably more likely to be really crappy
cards like twos and threes other than
aces because if they had an H they would
have played at that I think not worrying
about that is fun you don't worry about
it okay another example equity
calculation so it's the exact same
example as before but in this case the
probability distribution isn't over card
that could come all the kurds have
already come the probability
distribution is just over my opponents
hand so you know this is a same
calculation we calculated our equity is
25% and that's not a probability
distribution over cards come that's a
probability distribution over are the
least of our going to taint okay so
example 3 of calculating equity so this
one you can't really do by hand it's um
let's say you get it all in preflop with
Ace King suited against pocket
choose and you basically need a
calculators or certain websites that
help me do this and ace-king suited
against pocket twos if they don't have
it two of your suit is actually a very
small favorite which is kind of cool but
if you have this to a card spin you're
actually a slight under die okay so
right so so just make sure for all the
different all the different things
equity could mean equity could mean a
probability of a river card is
probability over the unknown a very good
calculator in generals poker sooo which
all have lots of examples of the my side
then you can download it via this link
here alright so this is an example of
using cooker soap so you know you can
put an exact calculation like let's say
you get it in with two of diamonds two
of spades
so pocket twos on the flop of five three
two versus a range where you know your
opponent is going to have a big pair
like pocket jacks plus you can actually
run it and your equity is eighty five
percent
we're socially surprisingly low I think
you know cuz it seems like you know
you've got three of a kind
they've only got a pair they have a two
chances to hit one of two products but
there's a lot of random stuff that can
happen like if they have h that they can
make it straight they can make a
backward flush the board would come to
more fives which counterfeits are three
of a kind deuces so this is another
example of calculating equity right so
this is a summary of the different
situations you might want to calculate
equity and yeah I recommend you download
poker so but it's you don't really have
to and I guess one question you could
ask is you know how you actually do this
at a table so essentially exactly if you
do this a lot while you're studying
about hands and thinking about poker
eventually I've been able to just
memorize a lot of situations in general
what the probabilities are or at least
what the correct decision is okay so now
let's talk about raising to win the
blind and antes okay so the antes an ant
is an extra small bets that each player
must put into the pot each hand and
these some to around the big blind and
they come in during the later stages of
the tournament and they're inexistent in
cash games so I sort of I sort of stuff
this under the rug in the earlier
examples
so in let me go back so like in here do
you see the 1200 in the middle so I
actually sort of stuck this under the
rug but that comes from each player
being forced to put in 200 which is one
tenth of the dues line at the start of
everything and if you're playing
tournament then this would usually be
the case antes will come in fairly soon
is you're playing cash games where you
just sit down and you can leave whatever
and you sit family just like we're your
own play money then there's usually no
antes but and you've actually make a
world of difference in terms of what you
want to do so it's not just the stakes
are bigger when there's an DS because
you know you don't want to just think of
it like there's extra money in the pot
every can its equivalent to the blinds
being bigger that's not true because you
also have to put in an ante so if the
blinds were proportionally we're here to
cover the antes you would have to be
raised to a bigger size to try to steal
the blinds but with Anton do you don't
need to raise through any bigger side to
try to seal the line so it's actually
very action driving it's very exciting
it makes it so that you basically you
want to play a very wide range of hands
and you really just want to be trying to
win the blind as often as possible
because waiting one pot with the NTAs is
so big ok so this is what it looks like
all right so the first thing I'm going
to say is you know if your answer point
tournament tonight is if no one has
raised it you really don't want to call
you want to raise you give yourself a
chance of winning the blind without
being in flock so I think the most
common beginner mistake a key poker
players beginner poker players make is
not raising when no one has ready to
perform so in this case it would be just
calling for two thousand and trying to
see a flop but the main issue is you're
giving the big blind they can just check
and Ketu fought for free where if you
raise you put them to a decision and
they might fold and you might just win
the pot for free without having to do
anything essentially so how much do you
raise when I say raise um so the minimum
rate size you can do is raising to
two big lines however this is a bit
small because you give the clients
fairly good odds to make a profitable
call although it's not a bit not bad
so so let me just talk a bit in general
about raising pay versus raising small
so the advantage of raising small is
that you're risking less like let's say
you raise and then the next person
rebated and then the next person goes
all-in right so you know probably those
two people have pretty good hands and
you want to fold if you raise to a small
size then you can fold any base lose
that much if I made you like five big
blinds then I'm losing a lot more but
what's the benefit of raising big is you
give other people worse odds because if
I only raised it to Big Bite let's
actually do this calculation let's say
here instead of going all-in
I've raised to two big blinds which is
four thousands right what odds am I
essentially giving the big blind to call
to call so think about it as so this is
actually in this very exact situation
this is a very common mistake I see
beginners make which is you raise the
only four thousand yeah so this any
positives in the potent it have to go
two thousand six forty one forty one but
there's also the small blind
so there's actually going to be nine
thousand essentially in the pot this is
yeah so it's going to be 8800 it's going
to be eighty eight hundred until
approximately 90,000 and they only have
to call two thousand to see the bug does
that make sense in everyone else so it's
so there are actually four point five to
one and you know h2 catalog shoot is a
great hand but a but there's there's no
hand that ace Jack offsuit is more than
a four point one four point five to one
favorite against so in some sense you
know it's basically even if they have
Josh to or whatever eight to think of
the think of the best possible case for
a Dewar's you're still not doing better
than the audience you're giving them
okay so but on there so on the other
hand though you really don't want to it
is really risky to raise more than two
point two five so I'm so a reasonable
rule of thumb might say to raise two
point two five big blinds and
tournaments I know it's pretty close to
do the registration to it's probably not
that bad
but roughly speaking I think this is a
reasonable rule of thumb
earlier you could try to raise me more I
think that sort of customary although I
don't think it's theoretically optimal
um you could you'll often see players
basically BP blind
especially when you watch like pro
players they'll raise it bigger but the
main reason is because they're the
better player by a lot and they're just
trying to make big pots which is
reasonable you know ace as you think
your if you're trying to just play big
pots and win big pots that in raising
the bigger size is fine but I don't
think there's any theoretical reason to
raise to more than 2.25 big blinds in
most situations other than white
inhalation cash games where it's where
all players have a lot of money then
it's a bit different because also in
cash games you're not worried about
you're not worried over seeing more
because you're not worried about losing
out of the tournament but okay so the
other thing is instead of raising you
should just go all-in
if the effective stack size is 12 big
blinds or less so recall the rationale
for raising big is to prevent others
from calling for cheap but the rationale
for ratings small is lose less if you
get rebate and tactical but twelve big
blinds it's sort of the point where it's
small enough that you never really want
to fold after committee to point to buy
a big blinds so if I only have 12 big
blinds I've A's 2.25 I've only got nine
point seven five laughs after you know
even if I get okay fine if I get raised
and relays maybe a home but even if I
get rebate once if I'm raising in the
first place you know my hand is going to
be reasonable like I'm it for those
who's told again I'm not going to raise
in the first place if I'm like I only
have like five feet or something so your
hand will be reasonable so this is sort
of beginner mistake number two is being
too surgical all in preflop so that's
where this east jack hand I should sheet
it a bit I so technically here's the
effective stack size is well the big one
has twelve and a half big blind but the
small more I only had seven and a half
so I definitely said the effective stack
size is less than twelve and I just went
all-in so that's definitely big bigger
mistake number two in tournaments is to
beat you're scared to go all-in free
fall
so what your goal essentially should be
oh sorry actually say the rule is if
there's so all the numbers I said assume
there's antes if there's no antes you
should change it to 10 big blind so the
threshold for going on should be less
because when there's no antes you don't
you want to be risking less because the
pot is smaller okay so yeah so overall
what you know when I talk about position
I talked about stack size essentially
what I'm trying to get the point across
is if you're just starting out you
players tend to make all decisions based
on their card it's definitely like I
have a pair of jacks I see my paragraphs
on this board I have a pair that's
pretty good and you sort of tend to
ignore what the effective stack size is
how much you're wagering and position
but experience pleasures the cards
actually not as much much last enough in
fact you know if you're playing if
you're doing optimal play you don't
income sense what your cards are you
just care what your range of cards are
at that point so experienced players
that are willing to raise the blinds
with much sleep your hand from good
positions rather than early position and
they're going to risk going all-in a lot
more frequently with a lot worse hands
with their sack sizes low so I want you
to think about that so so you know if
you're just starting out that's fine you
know if you're still trying to figure
out whether you have a straight and
stuff like that that's fine then that's
totally fine of you try to play hasty
steps on your cards but I want
everyone's goal by the end of the class
to be able to play based on these other
factors more so than your current okay
so that being said I'm going to give you
some concrete suggestions for incentive
for those of you might want to start
playing tonight of what hand you should
be playing from each position and so
here this is so most of the tournaments
will be having nine players per table
and so this is going to be roughly a
range I recommend to open so these are
these are the range of hands you should
be playing from the worst position so
under the gun that in nine handed table
so there's eight players like-minded you
could pick up really good hands so it's
easiest kings queens jacks Ace King
suited ace king offsuit ten ace Queen
suited ace queen oz oz okay so that's
great to click the list of hand so this
is a you know these are only premium
hand right this is like six point
percent of hands I think it's a very
premium range so no Titus's okay so yeah
because the thing to remember is only
the best hand out of nine hands at the
table is going to get the pot when
there's not a hint you know even though
the average hand is really bad the best
hand out of nine hands is always going
to be pretty good so to even think that
you have a chance you need to start with
a very premium Holden okay so so okay so
roughly what do you add as you go around
the tables for the second position I'm
going to post all these slides before
the tournament start by the way so you
don't need to feel a scramble to write
all this down I'm going to post it so so
this is from the second position I saw
that I put in black the hands that I
would open from the previous Edition and
I put in red at the hands that I would
open from that position
in addition so you know second position
there's one left player okay I'll gamble
with 7/8 Jack and queen H ten students
so we'll get it we'll get around the
table and then the brain tool will
slowly increase so also note that these
are very conservative ranges if you
watch like high-pitched ochre probably
the players will open a lot more hands
than what I'm recommending here but my
general experience has been when you're
just starting out to play poker it's
much easier to err on the side of being
too tight and being too loose so because
it's in some sense a lot easier to play
pocket aces than seven five student with
pocket aces you're always going to have
a pair of aces or better you just stack
that bad
and then when 75 suited you need to be
able to block very carefully you need to
sometimes be able to try to get value
when you just hit a pair of sevens and
it's just a lot harder so always so the
range I'm suggesting are very tight by
those poker standards by tight I mean
the conservative but I think that's the
right side to air on when you're just
starting so these are the range okay so
now we're going to get as we get to the
later position so this is low Jack's
we're opening more hands now any two
student broadway's so that hands like
Jack ten suited Queen ten suit it's
basically any two cards that are the
same suit
and both tenor higher so maybe I should
just run through this quickly so why is
being having your heart beat suited good
you get those right right so if it
suited you're more likely to make a bust
but if you have two unsuited codes then
there's two different flushes you
determine right so okay like if you have
a queen of diamonds gonna say that he
can make a diamond flush or a spade
flush but essentially that that argument
is wrong because there's two reasons why
tomorrow one is it's not moral if you
can see a need for the suit to make you
go flush and two is when you make the
flush yourself the more obvious you have
the flush like if there's like if you
only have one diamond even if it's the
ace of diamond once there's four
diamonds on the board it's way more
likely that you have a flush so you're
going to get paid off less where is if
you have two diamonds in your hand and
there's only three diamonds on the board
it's less susceptible of that hope you
have a potion okay so okay so hijack is
3 to the button so this is what I would
recommend okay so any care so here's our
terms are pretty good any suited 8 so
suited ace means any card less than any
hand with an 8 and into the card of the
same suit and needs to be connector by
that onion hands light basically two
cards that are next to each other and
also the same suit like ten nine ten of
spades United States or I need two
unsuited throg away cards so I do use a
lot of terminology here so yeah please
stop me if something is unclear you can
google to these I think so I okay so
yeah and suit of connectors are good so
like a hand like seven six two it is
often better than a hand like tens of
ten six suited you know even though the
ten is bigger than the six because 10 is
sort of a small enough card where it's
not that relevant the fact that is a big
curve but the fact that selling six is
connected and can hit a lot more
straight as very relevant
okay so we're cut off I'm just going to
show you on poker so because this or to
many jewelers but the thing I want you
to note is the percentage is thirty
percent right so remember under the guy
playing 6% so we've multiplied what how
bad our hands could be for us to play by
five and I think this is what I really
want to want you to try and do and I
think what a lot of new players don't do
it up is they always play the same cards
regardless of your position and then
even prettier on this button and
everyone are trying to be fold I'm not
going to play about 55% of hands you
know this is huge I want you to play
jacks three students who think Jack
you're suited is a good hand or a king
for offsuit or queen six Roxy okay so
okay so now what hymns do you play from
the small blind is it folded you so
let's compare opening from the small
blind you obey from the button so so
there's a lot line it's a bit different
now so yeah so I should so I should
mention this because when you're raising
from the button from the dealer if you
get cold you get to act last postponed
so I'm going to talk more about this in
future lectures but this is basically
called having position post flop and
having position is basically good yeah
I'll probably Penn dairies three men and
one polygon you yes yes if people
haven't folded essentially I'll talk
more about this in future classes but
essentially what you need to do is I so
like let's say this guy raised and
you're the button right yeah essentially
you need to consider what his ranges and
calculate your equity against his range
which again is red right so if
interpolation is essentially completely
different um so it's actually the first
guy who raised sort of just determined
sort of what the barrier to entry to the
pocket because essentially the first guy
raised its if it's from under the gun
you know he's telling you my range is
populate but even if you sort of lose it
they're going to be like pocket forwards
plots and like you know Queen ten suited
a lot basically it's saying you know if
you're playing a sick suited then you're
basically in
because my brain is way better than that
so essentially the first time you played
this hand sort of sets the tone on what
how would your hand needs to be yes okay
an excerpt a questionnaire so I'll talk
more about this in a future lecture but
essentially essentially that's what you
need to do okay so from the small blind
let's compare opening to the small blind
from opening the button so the issue
with opening the small blind is it's the
big blind calls you actually don't have
petition postbox the big blind gets you
act after you post ah so it's actually a
lot worse in some sense that opening
from the button because you don't get
you actual apps but it is better in the
sense that there's one fewer person to
get through and also you have let you
have plus you agent which is actually
really relevant because from the button
you know if you want to if the binder if
the blinds are 2,000 or 1000 in spite of
your legislators at the binder 2040 if
you want to steal the blinds in the
button anyone to do 2.25 you need to put
in nine right you to raise an idea and
you get your age of 90 but if you're
reading through the small lines you only
need to put in seventy more so you're
actually paying a smaller price to try
to steal advice but the factory Ryota
position is a very important negative so
I say all these factors balance out and
you can roughly play the same range of
hands from the small blind as you would
from the big blind
I think the reasonable rule of thumb but
the fact that you're out of position
hurts a lot less as facts get shallower
essentially a defective snack sizes get
a lot smaller so it's so you know you
could really drastically increase the
change it generally have like 10 big
blinds from the small blind okay um all
right so let me just do it you copy up
about this okay so actually all even see
you guys again if someone comes up with
a very good complaint about these
recommendations I'm giving you I'll give
us the last $20 Baker um okay so what
are some problems sort of okay so I'm
normally I get lots of complaints in
this section you already got one but you
can answer yes um they're very
reasonable right okay okay okay that's
that's a very good point so a lot of
people asking you know why would you
follow these if I follow these everyone
knows what I'm doing well
the point is
most of these for most of it even this
range right
it sort of encompasses enough hands so
this is where I'm talking about optimal
balance play I think you know even
though humans have in salt poker I think
roughly if you want to ask it you know I
would I would guess that roughly the
optimal range of things you open from
this position is something like this
it's going to be a looser but it's
something roughly like this you know
probably you want to probabilistically
play some smaller cards just so when the
flop comes to to four you can
potentially have it too but essentially
you're not doing that here because if
the flop comes three small cards then
you're going to be doing pretty well
with on your base pairs and if the flop
comes big card
you still got East King ace queen ace
Jack in your so yeah but the best but
that is the correct you know that is a
good that is a good complaint and if you
um so you know in theory if in theory
optimal to play seven seven some
fraction of the time
six-six sound fashion of the time I like
to to some fraction of the time but that
sort of making things really complicated
and you know if I don't to add two to to
the list because if you place you to
every single time then that's way too
loose you're just screwing money by
raising with two two against this many
players behind but you know so ideally
maybe with two - you should do a random
number generator and ten percent of the
time you play - - that would probably be
theoretically also um okay good that
would have done this but okay I'll give
it
yeah I think another problem with
playing really tight all the time is
that you are also very easily bullied
around the table it's a some way someone
bets and you know you really want to
play you doing on a fixed your shaker
Angel full and then you maybe miss out
on something that you shouldn't have to
depending on your condition right okay
okay yeah so yeah so these are pretty
tight in that you know it does gives
these other people incentives to raise a
lot because everyone can be floating a
lot because they're just waiting for
these really good name okay um okay yeah
that's that's good so okay are there any
other questions about these suggestions
ideas or other other other potential
complaints I'm going to give this gift
certificate to you unless someone
thanks you have a they have another
complaint okay okay so yeah I'll give
this to you um okay so all right
so--okay so this is something that I
didn't really address till I talk to I
so I talked about going all-in as well
as it's just breathing so how do these
ranges different um they say the answer
essentially is they don't really differ
so you know let's say you know here
these are the hand I told you to play
right let's say you're sort of small
enough you only have 12 big blinds with
antes and you're supposed to go all-in
instead of raised what which is the tens
to go all-in with it's roughly the same
range um so yeah I think as a decent
rule of thumb if you just go all in with
the same range you're not going to be
doing badly but when the effective stack
size is much smaller like let's say you
only have to be big blind then you can
drastically increase this range um okay
so when you're when you're effective
size is actually say 10 or or enough in
your effective size it's five big blinds
you know intuitively you might think I
can wager a lot I can wager a lot wider
a range of pain so here's the argument
the argument is I'm only risking five
big lines in the other case I was
risking 12 big blinds
why should I should be way more
aggressive with five big blinds than
twelve before right so that's the
argument but the reason why that
argument is wrong is because with five
big blinds you're going to get calls
every time the five big blinds you can't
just go on with seven to offsuit because
your opponent has such good optical
they're going to call you or it was
twelve big blind even though you're
risking Wars you also have more chances
of getting everyone to fold so even
though it seems like you're risking way
more in some sense you're not because
the more chips you're risking the more
likely it is that everyone else folds
does that aren't going to make sense to
everyone
so make sure you don't get tricked by
that because it is easy to get tripped
but the fact that you the fact that when
you have when you're risking you're
getting people to fold more means you're
actually not risking as much as you
think you are and it
that's like a common fallacy okay cool
so okay so I'm going so we're doing the
last part of the class so are there any
other questions so I know some of you
probably want to start playing tonight
and I definitely did not address and
everything you need but are there any
other questions roughly in terms of
opening and going all in that you might
want to know before like playing tonight
because I do think we have maybe five
extra minutes so I can answer some
questions there no no I don't want to
trim like bluff me
I said blossom bunch of cons but I
realize that ever explained so bluffing
essentially means you have a bad hand
and because you have such a bad man you
know the only way of winning that hand
is to get your opponent to fold so
basically you bet big to hope that your
opponent folds if you have a better
range like an average hand option you
actually don't want to be betting
because there's no point because when
you bet you're essentially just getting
adversely selected where your opponent
calls you when their hand is better and
you lose more money to a veteran hand
and your opponent folds when their hand
is worse so you're not making any money
from the worst hand and then with your
best hand you wanted that to try to get
your opponent to call and increase the
amount that you win and we call this
value Vedic so I'm going to get more
into this more into this in future
lectures but essentially in poker the
paradigm you want to play is you want to
value bet your very best hand and then
you want to basically check and try to
get you showing like try to show your
hand on the river with your medium hands
and also bet with your bad hand to try
to get your opponent to fold better
hands
okay so okay I'm going to get to the
last part now okay so quick test okay so
here what would you do it folded you
you're in the hijack you have a size of
clubs so someone it's just what would
you do what would your play be cool okay
great so not not hot that's that was
mistaken or once you not do you always
want to raise the blind chick soldiers
but it is fine it's like that it's like
we're all here to learn about these
now should I go all under China's raised
to dive to 2004 or 50 which is you point
your phone I should go all-in so Kato I
think it's not shareholding is raised do
450 buy it I said if it's 10 big blinds
there's no aunty right so you need 10 or
less and you have 10 so going on I think
okay so we decided to go all-in and yeah
so so roughly this is one so there are
Nash calculators there are they're
complicated but if you run this through
a Nash equilibrium calculator this is
roughly what you should be going all-in
with okay so we go all-in
so this range is a bit different than
what I showed you before because this is
this is an actual Nash population just
not just my recommendation it's going to
be wider than what you saw before but
that's fun
okay so now here's this guy you're
seeing on okay so I'm going to show you
how to do a quick calculation of what
equity you need to call here and I'm
gonna um yeah so what equity you need to
call here so let's straight up pot odds
calculation says you're getting twenty
three to twenty or Union or one point
nine five to one so you roughly need
46.5% equities you call added this
player but there's two players left
right there's a graphic split you see
why had not hold it c1 and c2 both have
cards so you actually need more than
forty six point five percent equity
because the calculation of 46.5% assumes
c1 and c2 can't wake up with populations
so you know you can just so hope you're
so it's very good for this and you can
do this right now I taught you
everything you need to do these
calculations and a full result is also
easy to figure out how to use you can
essentially just plug it you know you
look at pocket finds it had 48 percent
you need forty six point five percent
and I said you need a bit more than
forty six point five due to the fact
that there's two players behind so
pocket finds you know it's good enough
okay well call a sign suited
I'll call so I'm just showing you some
calculations on Booker sews it really is
a really good tool um so you can do some
calculations and you okay so so
basically okay the day called um
and the hands I showed you here is
actually sort of the worst hand that
it's plexi do you call it pocket fives
case nine suited plus so he thank you
good plus means a Stein Tuesday's ten
suited ace Jack sees all the hand that
are strictly better than these nine
suited ace 10 off suit king queen suited
okay so now as the last player here do
you call the king queen to this um just
rough guess how many of you intuitively
would call the king queen suited so
cheered players have already gone all-in
how is so most of it would fold
oh you guys are called okay so it turns
out at least according to the nash
calculator which is not so so here you
calculate the pot odd and this is an
exact calculation because there's no
more playing time so you just have to
like do i have twenty nine point five
percent equity and it's basically if you
if I assume that player one and player
two are playing according to Nash
equilibrium or optimal Manges you
actually have way more than it up you
actually have thirty four percent where
you only need is twenty five percent so
this is sort of a trick question I set
up the trick was keeping you doesn't
seem like you should hand but against
two other hands it's actually relatively
a very good hint you know against one
other hand that you just have a pair and
you're behind you have an ace most of
the time in here behind but against two
other hands you actually have really
good equity because when you hit a king
or queen of the big care you can also
hit it straights and flushes with king
queen suited and your equity against two
other hand is very good okay so you have
way more than enough so so they call
okay so so we're going to get them it's
all in free fall okay so who are the
people I gave these cards do joy or so
you guys can come up to the front and
I'm going to hand you your card this is
the people who like these gift
certificates to do I said okay um
yes a sale okay so beginning so what I
want you going to do is okay so these
are the hands people went all in with
okay so he was the first person to
answer okay so you get to pick which
hand do you want yeah I'll go with Jack
Jack okay so I'm going to call it Colin
is going to take Jack Jack okay so
what's your name Kevin Kevin Kevin which
anyone so he took Jack Jack which of
these remaining is you were second right
yeah you were okay
okay where's Han Ji Won Owen king
okay so he's gonna say King Queens it is
there you can take a scientific plus
okay so so this is okay this is sort of
mean but I want to show you guys
personnel poker works when you already
won you won $20 so we're going to put
your right hand and feel when the pain
is going to get all 60 okay so okay so
this is your forward predetermine a so
this is a free fall back buddy yeah so
it is it is just pretty good time okay
so so looks like you guys did very well
you guys fixed correctly you got to pick
first you pick the best hand with equity
of two thirty four point seven three you
got thirty three point nine five
normally if it's a hundred thirty one
point life alright okay to the Boston
six seven eight so let's look at the
probabilities now Jack's is still had
eight five has picked up a lot of out
king queen of diamonds is not looking
too good but they picked up one diamond
okay darn ten to nine of Hearts so I'm
sorry waitressing Queens I'm Jack
so George you're the running
and you need the tag if you want to
cheer a third party or okay flora what
are you looking for Tenderheart oh okay
so you want me to screaming I'm gonna
press it on the count of three okay you
want to be screaming ten or and you want
to be screaming nothing yeah Middle
Tennessee okay so don't you do this
there's gonna be more of these different
during class oh my good mate in class
you're going to get I guess
[Applause]